hello everyone we're just going to be
starting here in a few more minutes
lane
are you there
uh yes i'm here
all right perfect
all right well i guess we can get
started we're just gonna be starting
here in a few
okay yeah so i think i have already
okay um welcome everyone uh we're gonna
get started today uh today this is the
orientation for data science uh for
biomedical data
um so for some of you that have already
participated in the orientation that
happened last week uh this introduction
will be a little a bit of review for you
uh but for those of you that were not
able to come to that orientation this
will be fresh information
so first off i want to thank lsu biomed
as well as lvrn for funding these
training modules available biomed is
under lsu it's a group of cores and it
stands for the division of biotechnology
and molecular medicine that's the
biomed down here gene lab is one of the
cores within biomed and i'll talk a
little bit more about that at the end of
the
lecture here
and then lbrn is louisiana biomedical
research network
which is a consortium of universities
that work together
to further louisiana's research
potential as through collaboration and
communication but
that aside let's go ahead and get
started as to uh the information that
you guys are here for today
so
a little bit of overview about what
these training models are so these
training modules are designed to be
completely asynchronous and that is
because many of us have very big busy
schedules right so the opportunities
available here for you to
jump in and jump out around your
schedule and work with on your time
timelines um really should benefit you
here
additionally
you're not in this alone so the purpose
of these programs is to help guide you
through the information and provide you
with interactions similar to how you
would with say a professor or an expert
in the field that would be teaching a
similar course so
for these training models you'll have
access to a variety of mentors that will
interact with you both through lectures
as well as be accessible through online
chat
which has a variety of options for you
to reach out to them and email of course
and
once you have gone through the program
once you've reached the completion of
the program you will receive a
certificate so that you can prove that
you completed this training module and
have a better understanding of data
science
now depending on what institution you
come from that certificate will look a
little different so if you come from lsu
your certificate will be customized to
lsu and be signed by dr gus casoulis
if you come from lbrn your certificate
will also be customized but always be
signed by
the lbrns bioinformatics core lead chris
taylor
if you are not part of lsu or lbrn your
certificate will be
similar to a standardized certificate
that you would receive if you completed
the program independently
so that being said there are three main
things that you're going to utilize um
while you go through these programs that
are going to help you through the lesson
plans or you'll interact with frequently
the biggest one you're going to interact
with frequently is the omixlogic portal
i'm going to show you how to register
for that in a little bit um the mxlogic
portal is essentially the location of
the website you're going to go to and
access all of your lesson plans where
you're going to see your syllabus for
the program as well as
access a variety of mentor interaction
options
the next thing that you're going to
interact with fairly frequently is the
tbio platform so the tbio platform is
designed to allow you to input
bioinformatics acquired data
and then run it through a various
pipeline of analyses so that you can go
through the normal process that a
bioinformatician would uh to analyze the
different data except this is much
easier for those that don't have the
expertise
to perform the analyses uh through their
own coding
however that you're not just going to be
using this platform you are going to
learn how to code to some extent
this program in particular is going to
involve much more coding uh than than
the other two that are being offered
this semester so
you're going to be doing this partially
because you guys are a coding course you
will have some uh work with the coding
playground
and so the coding playground is
essentially a virtual or online
playground or a coding environment so
that you can practice your coding online
without having to establish a coding
environment on your computer
now because you guys are coding
based training module you'll likely also
have to set up a coding environment on
your own computer but this as you learn
will be available to you so you don't
have to uh go through that process right
away
so this is an intermediate based
difficulty course this basically means
that it's targeted towards individuals
that have an understanding of both
biological and data science concepts as
well as some experience with statistics
and some experience with coding
you don't have to be experts on any of
these things but the expectation is that
you are able to understand some of the
information given to you from the get-go
so this there are two other difficulty
level offered training programs this
semester which we'll be talking about
transcriptomics tomorrow if you're still
interested
and we were talking about uh
introduction to bioinformatics yesterday
and that recording will be available
online
so what exactly is this training module
so this training module the orientation
is obviously today but you have access
available to you already if you've
registered
this training module is designed to help
you analyze bioinformatic data that's
from everything from data wrangling all
the way through visualizing your data
many of us have seen visualized
bioinformatic data if you work in
biomedical field
but this course is designed this
training model is designed to help you
go through uh the actual steps and
understand the analyses that are going
on behind the data visualization because
there's a lot of steps to get to that
visualizations point
some of the concepts you're going to
cover
um is statistical concepts as their and
their applications to biological data
machine learning and deep learning
python in our coding as well as coding
challenges that you can start to
understand how to do the coding yourself
as well as how data sharing now you're
also going to have a variety of ways to
learn this it's hands-on exercises
there's tutorials uh there's lessons
there's the mentor guided lectures
there's plenty of learning opportunities
here uh that will help lead you through
this process
and it's not just going to be uh
conceptual applications this training
module is targeted to also be able to
practically apply this information in
your research world in your clinical
world and the variety of other
applications that data science finds
itself in
and like i said you're going to be able
to practice this as you go so you're not
going to be stuck just learning uh the
concepts
so i'm not going to go through all the
details of the lecture or all the
syllabus but these are uh here's your
syllabus these are the finalized dates
uh later on ilia will go into more
detail about that
additionally there are other resources
available to you especially if you're
coming from lsu or lbrn
like i mentioned the very beginning
there's lsu gene lab and lsu team lab is
available to everyone within the lsu
network or the lbrn network
basically what lsu genelab is designed
for us to reside is to provide
consulting as well as a variety of
experimental services which range from
next generation sequencing all the way
to cell automated cell counting i listed
a few of those services here
this is not their full list
but this
laboratory and this service laboratory
is available to anyone within those
networks and can very much help your
research if you're not familiar with one
of these techniques
additionally lbrn like i mentioned chris
taylor
is associated here with the
bioinformatics biostatistics and
computational biology core
this core is basically designed to
provide consulting mentorship and
training
focused in bioinformatics and data
science fields and how they're applied
to biological data now this is targeted
towards faculty and pi so keep that in
mind
if you reach out to them
this program is also designed to create
a project at the end now i did want to
give this information to individuals
that every year lbrn holds a conference
focused on computational biology and
bioinformatics this is usually around
april or springtime um so once you
complete the project in this training
module you'll have the opportunity to
present that project at this particular
conference or any conference of your
your choosing if you're interested in
that
additionally uh some new information i
received today is that there is also a
master's program focused on
bioinformatics available at the lsu
health center in new orleans
so if you're interested you can look
that up uh yourself if you want to
continue your your knowledge into the
bioinformatic field
and finally if you're a faculty member
or a pi at another institution and
you're interested in having these
programs or training models offered at
your institution you can contact ilya
brodsky who is the ceo of pine biotech
who is offering these training models at
illya at pine bio
for more information
so i'm going to hold here before i show
you how to register
but i'll take any questions if anyone
has any questions about this process
itself
if not we're going to move on to the
registration
no sir
okay so if we don't have any questions
i'm gonna go ahead and switch screens
here
i'm going to show you how to register on
the omixlogic portal
so for those of you that have not done
this already if you're interested in
this training module you have to
register on omxlogic before we can add
you to the the course the training model
so to do so you're going to want to go
to learn.omixlogic.com
when you come to this page
you will be able to see
clearly in the front how to register for
free
and they put that link in the chat
um i will also mention before i go
through this that there is another
website i'll put the link in the chat
that will go through all the other
training programs and training modules
that are offered at lsu or through the
lsu biomed and lbrn network this
semester so you can go to that link if
you're interested in the other training
modules
but like i said
go to learn.mxlogic.com to register for
any of these training models the way to
do so is to click register for free down
here
and once it loads up you'll see on the
right hand side a sign in or sign up
section
all you have to do once you get to this
section if you already have an account
you can sign in here
if you don't already have an account
there will be a small button you'll have
to click to
expand the information
to allow you to register for
learn.mxlogic.com
okay so here so if you already have an
account you'll sign in here uh if you
don't click on create an account right
here this box will expand for you and
give you and ask you a few a little bit
more information like your name the
institution that you're with uh et
cetera et cetera but since i already
have an account i'm gonna go ahead and
log in so i can show you a brief uh
introduction of the profile on mxlogic
and how to access the information that
you'll need to access for this training
so when you log in you'll open up to
this page i recommend going to your
profile by clicking on right here
welcome back your email will be listed
it'll take you to your profile
once you're added to the training module
you'll have two ways to access the
syllabus easily from your profile the
first one would be come down here and
click on the data science badge
the other way to do so would be go over
here to the programs tab at the top of
your profile page
click on that
and once this loads you're going to go
to biomed data science for biomedical
data
before i jump there i do want to show
you how to access some other things here
on your profile page uh one that you'll
use frequently is your courses so once
you have started a asynchronous course
you're going to be able to find it under
the course tabs to continue it because
again this is on your schedule and then
you might not always be able to complete
a lesson in one sitting but what you can
do is come to the courses tab and find
whatever courses you have started and
easily access them later on
you'll also be able to access any
certificates you receive
and i can show you what one of these
looks like now
once this loads
this is what your certificate of
completion will look like and like i
said depending on the institution you
come from it'll be more customized and
it'll be signed by a different
individual but if you're coming from an
outside institution it will look very
similar to this and it'll be signed by
an individual associated with pine
biotech
so if i go back here i'm going to show
you the syllabus page very briefly
under the programs tab like i said you
can go to your syllabus at any time
or the program page where you'll find
your syllabus
so here is your program page if you have
not registered already you will not have
this pop up here this is because i've
already been registered if you haven't
already registered if you go to this
page this link you'll be able to scroll
down and you'll be able to find pricing
in this area about how to access the
program
but since you're most of you should
already be registered
you'll be able to scroll down and you'll
find today's the first lesson so here's
your find the syllabus information and
also the information for each individual
lesson today being october 7th you can
see this is the topics that are going to
be covered today and here are the
associated resources that you should uh
go through
after this lesson
now once you complete everything with
this lesson you'll be able to click
complete complete lesson here
and once you have done that for every
single lesson in the program you'll
receive your certificate
okay so that being said that's all i'm
going to cover today i'm going to go
ahead and hand off uh to ilia with pine
biotech and he'll go over some more
details about the training program
all right thank you very much lane and
welcome everyone good to see that
everyone has joined and i'm going to
start sharing my screen
so what i want to do in my part of the
presentation is go over a little bit
what we will cover in each one of these
parts so
already lane mentioned that we will be
talking about
data science we'll be talking about
machine learning and we'll be
speaking a lot more in detail about
every aspect of these things now the
major objective of this data science
program and how it is different from
some of the other programs that we've
been talking about yesterday and we'll
talk about tomorrow is that this
particular
program is designed to give you some
more general skills in addition to your
ability to analyze biomedical data so
what do i mean by that first of all
data science in itself is very similar
to bioinformatics so you could define
bioinformatics as the intersection of
computational tools and and methods to
organize and manage your data with a
focus on biology whereas data science is
a lot more general so it could be
applied to a lot more different
applications besides biology itself and
so you can kind of say that
bioinformatics combines a lot of the
same elements but with this unique focus
on biology
at the same time when people hear the
word bioinformatics that tend to think
of very specific applications of
bioinformatics so people would think
about blast and kind of sequence
alignment and things like that however i
want to talk today about how the nature
of sequencing data is changing and a lot
of the ways that we analyze this data is
also changing
bringing to the forefront this need to
have
data wrangling data analysis data
visualization and machine learning
skills in what we are able to do and so
i'll talk a little bit more about what
we will be able to do in the context of
this particular program to help you uh
come kind of get those skills
so the program will combine three main
modules besides some introductory
material these are the three main
modules that you will have to complete
bioml
logic biomlr and biomel python
now bioml simply stands for uh you know
bio uh
bio data and ml stands for machine
learning but essentially it will cover
statistical analysis and machine
learning that starts from data
preparation for statistical analysis all
the way to interpretation of what you
have been able to identify using a
variety of analytical methods
so besides these three
modules there are some additional
modules that you can
choose to complete they're not a
requirement so for those of you that
have
less background in biology we recommend
the course called bytes and molecules
kind of talks a lot about how to apply
uh different types of
methods and bioinformatics to different
domains like
let's say medical
or maybe basic biology it also
introduces a lot of the
terminology that you would have to
know to
orient yourself so if you come from more
of an engineering background maybe
you're not so sure what's the difference
between a gene and a mutation exon in
intron
or maybe sequencing dna as opposed to
rna and and what does that mean in terms
of data
because a lot of the words um are used
in the in a different way
so that's something that you can clarify
in those introductory modules and then
for some of you that do not have any
background in engineering so you have
not done any coding at all there are
some introductory modules like
introduction to bioinformatics in r and
introduction to bioinformatics in python
so those would be useful for anyone that
comes without any coding experience
what these modules provide are some
exercises that clarify what is the
problem or why are we doing what we're
doing
how to address this problem from a
coding perspective how to use existing
code and maybe modify some of the
settings and outputs and then apply them
in an effective way to a data so here
you can see an example from getting
started with bioinformatics and r
how to load data how to visualize it
maybe how to read different types of
data maybe tables or sequences and how
to apply some of these commonly used
bioinformatics tools so this is just to
get you started when you move on to the
more advanced courses like biomel and
python for example you can see that they
will use project examples with curated
data sets taken from publications so in
other words a lot of the methods will
try to replicate the analysis done in
that publication
having to code every step of the way
to be able to understand what is the
method what are some of the assumptions
about the data and how can you choose
between the different methods to really
select the one that is most useful in
the context of the research question
posed by these different data sets
now besides that we have this parallel
so the exact same thing that you will
learn in r
you can learn in python
y r in python the primary reason is
because r
has a lot of commonly used packages you
will find typically outputs from
different r packages and publications
a lot of the statistical analysis is
very easy to use with kind of beautiful
visualization right out of the box with
minimal modification so that's why r is
very popular in bioinformatics you have
a whole
series of packages being developed
every day to address new types of data
and new types of analyses
at the same time in python it seems like
some of the things are going to be a
little bit more challenging in terms of
let's say visualization and making these
beautiful figures that you can just take
and use in your publication but a lot of
times once you get into the syntax
python is
tends to be something that people feel
much more comfortable with after they've
kind of overcome this initial stage of
some technical things that you just have
to practice and know so these two
package or these two languages are very
popular and we'll talk a lot about how
to get started how to set up your
environment and eventually how to use
those in the context of a data set that
you choose or you pick for your project
you know just to kind of give you more
in-depth information about how this is
actually going to work so here's an
example from the python
version of the course you can see that
there are several different sections
here you essentially will be able to
learn the code syntax just by reading
about the code it will explain every
single piece of the code what are we
trying to do import packages loading
data removing specific
portions of the data manipulating our
data and then you can practice so
essentially you can
replicate this code run it and test your
results whether your results are correct
or not and so as you saw here in this
little video you essentially run that
piece of code right in the browser and
it will tell you whether your result is
correct
besides that you will then be able to
take this code and modify it so that you
understand how to apply it to different
types of data sets so each exercise is
going to be first to understand the
objectives and strategies
then to learn the syntax or how to code
this in a particular language like
python
then how to test your understanding in
these coding challenges and so for the
coding challenges you will get a link to
a jupyter notebook
that will typically have some initial
code and then once you
look through that code you'll give be
given an assignment how to complete it
how to maybe take something that you've
learned in the lesson and apply it and
you know write it out in code and make
sure that that code works so a jupyter
notebook looks like this essentially
it's a
like a google
document in this case this is a google
colab
where you can take each portion of your
code and run it right in the browser
in this example all of the code is
already written for you but in some
cases you will have to modify or maybe
write full pieces of code yourself and
that way you'll learn
how not to only learn about the syntax
how to also write it all out yourself
so let's talk a little bit about what
the different sections are going to
cover and so this is an overview of all
of the topics that we are going to be
covering in this program so we're going
to divide it into three different parts
the first part is introduction the
second part is methodology how to
understand and apply these methods and
the last section is actually about the
application to particular projects and
so the first session is going to give
you a sense of comics data terminology
and key concepts that you just have to
know to get started the second portion
will tell you about the details of the
methods what's the difference between
different clustering methods or how to
do dimensionality reduction using
different techniques for different types
of data and what are the differences
between statistical analysis methods and
machine learning methods or deep
learning methods and then finally you
will get introduced to a number of
different research publications with
curated data sets and you will see how
this is used in clinical applications in
biomedical research and in different
aspects of what the industry is doing
with clinical trials or with designing
new drugs and things like that
so let's uh talk a little bit more about
the different challenges that you will
should be able to address
once you complete this full program
typically when people think of big data
they think of data that
is intuitive and easy to understand and
in this case especially in the world of
biomedical research typically that is
not true so there are several different
challenges around it first this data is
unintuitive so you really have to have a
lot of additional information to
understand what the data describes and
number two the data is not structured so
as you can imagine
a lot of these data sets that i have
here on the screen come in their
original form in an unstructured way you
cannot just take them and analyze them
so the first challenge that you should
be able to do after this program is to
structure data and prepare it for
analysis
what kinds of data are we going to be
dealing with primarily we're going to be
talking about omics data this includes
phenomics genomics or dna variation
epigenomics like bisulfite sequencing so
dna methylation or chipseek where you're
looking at histone modifications
and transcriptomic data including some
other types of data sets like
metagenomics so all of these data sets
have to be processed to be useful and
we'll briefly touch on how to process
data because essentially sequencing data
looks like this you have short reads
those short reads have to be aligned to
the reference genome and only after they
have been aligned to the right place on
the genome you can actually quantify how
many you have and translate this into
structured data that is quantified so
you actually have numbers associated
with features like genes and samples
that represent some biological
conditions that we can compare and
contrast
to do that you essentially have to know
some of the basic ways that some of
these coding languages deal with data
and the way they they deal with data in
this example we're going to look at
python so in python you have two major
packages that allow you to work with
matrices that essentially represent
numeric data that you can manipulate and
work with and pandas that allows you to
work with data frames and so we will
learn about how to take this kind of
data prepared for analysis
load it into the environment that we're
working in for example r or python and
then that will make it ready to explore
and so once we've loaded the data we
will start looking at data properties so
how can we
estimate different important parameters
like distribution
like for example
different ways of normalizing data to
check that the data is
kind of consistent with our assumptions
about the data and how to essentially
prepare this data for the method that we
will use in the analysis because
in a typical way that method will have
some expectations about the data that
are important to make this analysis
correct and make it interpretable
as a part of that we will talk about
different ways to visualize data an
important part of kind of playing around
with the data is being able to
for example extract different portions
of your data frame combine them together
to find a data set that you need for
example if you're talking about
you know different types of conditions
and those conditions are defined by
different sexes different ages different
disease stages you might want to look at
just some of those and so one way to do
that is you have different types of
categorical data and you want to create
a data frame so that you can analyze
that and that's called crosstabs
the other way is you can compare
categorical groups so for example
different age groups different sexes
different disease types and then you can
create summary of continuous data for
example gene expression to visualize it
and make it
kind of statistically
comparable between different groups
and finally we'll talk about how to
analyze and visualize continuous data so
if you have for example two genes and
you have many samples that are defined
by those genes or in the other way
around you have many genes defined by
two samples how can you visualize the
combination of this continuous data for
example in a scatter plot so we'll talk
a lot about visualization
and so you will be able to take
unstructured data which could be gene
expression could be metagenomics or even
could be survey data and essentially
make sense of them and visually
presentable so here you can see a bar
plot a
pie chart so those are some simple tasks
that you should be able to do after you
complete this training
what essentially that gives you is some
method of manipulating your data so from
random patterns like you see here you
will get patterns that could be
biologically interpretable right and you
will be able to then differentiate
between different types of signals to
know that they are different and to
start thinking about how do you analyze
many of these types of signals as you go
into the analysis stage
so we talked here
spoke about data processing essentially
preparing your data for analysis and
then starting to explore it and so
as you complete the full program you
should be able to understand the
significance of experimental design how
the data was generated to then how the
data is typically processed cleaned
prepared for analysis
then what is the major trend in your
data that you can use to define your
statistical analysis and pick the right
model and then essentially use the
analysis results to make interpretations
as well as generalizations about
whatever this data represents
so
major kind of part of that is
statistical analysis and what we'll do
in the statistical analysis section is
we'll talk a little bit about different
ways that you can make sure that your
analysis has
some significance so what is that
significance defined by what are p
values what are full changes what are
those uh error bars that we typically
see right so we'll talk a little bit
about those concepts because they're
extremely important for us to understand
before we jump into these more
complicated methods of analysis like
machine learning
so you will be able to for example use
packages that can simplify your your
comparison between multiple types of
data and make sure that you understand
different parameters like level of
correlation or like i said p values and
things like that you'll be able to
extract different
elements like genes based on statistical
properties of an analysis
you'll be able to understand how to use
those different statistical parameters
correctly you will be able to also test
and validate that what you are finding
is consistent with biological literature
or research literature out there
you will also be able to
summarize your data in intuitive and
useful visual format so here we have a
heat map and you will have a whole way
of going through the data to kind of
summarize the significant part of that
data based on your experimental design
or the contrast that you've built into
your analysis
we will also talk about different
exercises that will combine elements of
loading data running loops
making sure that you know how to filter
and save different components that you
have in your data maybe even print
reports that was going to be very useful
when you want to share your results with
somebody else visualize data and make
complex outputs and we will do that both
in r as i mentioned again in r you have
very easy to use predefined packages or
python where you have to put a little
bit more work into
maybe sorting the data before you
visualize it and you also have to
understand the different elements of the
syntax so we will go through that as
well
then we will come to kind of one of the
major objectives of such programs and
and one of the major objectives when you
get to know your data closely
is how to differentiate signal from
noise
so i really like this picture here on
top you can see that even here the
signal is present right so you can
clearly see that there's something there
there's kind of a snapshot of some
difference but the goal of the analysis
is to really focus on the difference
and distinguish them or separate the
signal from the noise and to do that in
statistics typically we can use a model
for the noise
with some assumption about the data so
for example if the data was randomly
generated we can then assume that the
noise is representative of that
randomness and we actually have a
formula here for noise that kind of
helps us explain or model this noise and
so we can start putting together the
different elements
that help us understand and focus on the
signal
machine learning in many cases uses the
same principles but it also relies on
algorithms to
take those differences between signal
and noise and be able to apply them in
more sophisticated ways
so that's why next we will turn to data
mining and classification and
essentially go over some of the commonly
used what's called conventional machine
learning approaches these approaches
have been kind of popular and used since
the 1950s really so for a long time
in the last decade or so they have
become much more popular and much more
easy to use for a number of different
reasons including complexity of data the
volume of data and computational tools
and technologies that we now have in our
uh you know
made accessible to really be able to use
them in a much simpler way
to really understand each one of these
methods we will also make different
comparisons so that we understand the
significance of different elements and
different outputs of these methods
because in a lot of cases people just
apply them without a lot of
understanding without understanding of
how to use these settings in some
meaningful way and so we'll go into the
detail and we'll be able to really look
at each method in depth understand how
they are related to each other how to
compare and contrast
those different methods what do they
essentially mean what are some of the
algorithms behind these data and how can
we essentially explore our data and
prepared for analysis so that we know
that we are using the right kinds of
assumptions and the right kinds of
methods and they really make the
analysis interpretable so we will kind
of review all of these methods in some
detail to make sure that everybody
understands also what goes on behind the
scenes
we'll also introduce
you to some standard ways of
implementing this using
such packages like
cicit or scikit so how scientific
methods are used in python including
different packages that are commonly
used for this in for example in our
language
we'll also try to address some of the
linear algebra kind of
elements of machine learning so here you
have uh singular value decomposition for
pca so we'll we'll try to make sure that
in some layman terms everybody
understands where this uh kind of
analysis comes from uh we'll talk about
how this is actually useful to
understand where this comes from because
now you will understand the significance
of different properties of these objects
that are produced by python and r
packages and you can actually get a lot
more information out of that
and you will be able to
compare and contrast different methods
for optimization and for
really making them
you know less over fit and more
generalizable
now in many cases like i mentioned uh
these methods include some algorithmic
under understanding and so we will talk
briefly about some of the algorithmic
components here as well we'll talk about
feature selection as an example of a
greedy algorithm we'll kind of give
simple illustrations of how you can
understand these different algorithms
and how they rely on some of the
statistical properties of your data as
well as the different types of
assumptions that this algorithm will
have so that you know what is the
meaning of the different settings when
you try to run these analyses and also
understand the outputs and where they
came from so what is the reason why
you're seeing what you're seeing in the
output of these particular data sets
we'll also talk about different
applications of these methods to a
variety of different types of biomedical
omics data so we'll talk about it in the
context of diagnostics and cancer
biology we'll talk a little bit about
single cell and tissue composition as
well as microbiome and infection or how
we can use this proportionate data to
infer some meaning about different
conditions in terms of diversity
complexity and and things like that so i
think a lot of exciting applications of
some of these data science methods now
as a result you will also be able to
read data and understand what each data
set represents you will be able to
distinguish between different methods
that are typically mentioned in
publication so here you can see one of
the publications that we will use it has
all of these terms support vector
machines random forests uh you know
different molecular profiles so you'll
be able to kind of read some of these
methods and understand what they mean
and actually know how to implement these
methods and as i mentioned we will
provide different curated examples
within the course that you can then
choose to expand on essentially all of
these curated data sets are provided as
a standalone module you can go through
it and understand how the authors
perform the analysis and what does the
analysis really mean what did they
actually publish on
so to summarize the program is going to
be
separated into three different parts the
first part is going to give you some
introductory materials so that you
understand the terminology and key
concepts that you will need to be
successful in this module
the second part will focus on different
methods and in-depth understanding of
the methods parameters and settings and
kind of the logic behind those methods
and then finally you will be introduced
to a number of different projects that
you can use to first of all understand
how these methods have been used by
experts that wrote the publication and
then potentially choose to develop a
project of your own using some of these
methods that you have learned how to
code and essentially the objective of
having a lot of these exercises done in
a jupiter notebook is also to provide
you with a whole collection of different
scripts that you understand that you can
modify that you can read and then have a
little differences in data sets that you
know how to adjust the code for so that
you can essentially use this for your
own
project
so
at this point i want to
ask if anyone has any questions that i
can answer
um
so if you do have any questions
please put them into the chat box
uh if there are questions that i that
have been posted already and i have not
seen maybe
you can help me elaine or just be
see what i need to answer
okay
so
if there are no other questions
um
okay um one second
what is the best language um
okay
so it's a good question what is the best
language python and r um you know i
don't know if there's such a thing as
the best one so there's a funny kind of
answer that i read about this so
has anyone here heard about visual basic
like in excel you can write vba scripts
yeah so you know that came around a long
time ago right visual basic was since
the beginning of excel it's been around
and many people complained about visual
basic it's a very difficult uh kind of
thing to learn and then once you learn a
lot of things don't work right so
people have been talking about this
visual basic language disappearing
and the fact is that today many people
still use visual basic and use it
effectively if they have learned and
kind of applied it in an effective way i
think in a similar way it's difficult to
say that you know one language
supersedes completely another language
and everybody just goes and learns a new
language and that becomes the best the
most popular the most efficient i think
what we are seeing is that a lot of
people use these languages for different
purposes for example a lot of people in
statistics use r
and are encouraged to use r
particularly because there are so many
different easy to use packages and so if
we see bioinformatics from that
perspective as a way to analyze our data
explore our data i think r is a very
useful
way to get started i think it's
intuitive you know depending on who you
talk to some people like it some people
don't like it but it's a good
you know well-adopted and kind of
bioinformatically
validated language
python i think is easier in terms of
syntax it has less you know i think
writing in python once you understand
kind of the logic behind it becomes
easier but it's more work so it's not
just like modify a couple of pieces of
uh how you call some function and it
just works you have to start doing loops
and you have to filter and you have to
call different packages so a lot of this
i think tends to be a little bit more
complicated in python but
python seems to be much more adopted in
other fields for example besides
bioinformatics
uh in other fields it's a very useful
language to know
um okay so how
how can you start
again like lane
mentioned
you can start by first of all taking a
look at the full syllabus page which is
right here and i'm going to paste this
in the chat
and this link will kind of give you an a
good overview of everything that's
and provide you with some links
so if you scroll down we'll kind of talk
about some of the major things that we
will cover and give you a good overview
of the full syllabus
now if you want to then participate in
the program you essentially can have two
different ways one if you are already at
lsu or lbrn
and then the best way is to do it
through ilab
and we have a short video that we will
send by email after this on how to do
this on ilab if you are from lsu or lbrn
what's important to remember is that for
lsu and lb lbrn really
you can be a student you could be
faculty you can also offer this to your
students as well if you think that they
could benefit from such training and the
training as already mentioned is
asynchronous so you can essentially just
use the whole semester to complete all
of these modules and get your
certificate
now once you're here or let's say you're
not from lbrn or lsu what you need to do
is you need to sign up on the portal so
let me ask you how many of you have
already signed up on the omixlogic
portal
maybe if you have signed up put a number
one
in the chat box
okay great thank you everyone and and uh
isa uh i will address your question in
just a second okay so if you have not
yet signed up on this portal this portal
is free and i'll just show you a little
bit how you can use this portal so this
portal is free and it has everything
that you need to get started and grow so
essentially from
very basics if you're completely new to
bioinformatics
all the way to wanting to use
bioinformatics in a more effective way
to do research you can do this through
this portal
once you're signed up you can just
simply go to the courses page
and on the courses page you will have
several different ways that you can
navigate the uh material that you have
here you have tags here on the side so
for example you can look at data science
courses or machine learning courses
right
you have these collections so for
example getting started or
bioinformatics in r by informatics in
python so different categories of
courses are organized right here
you can also look
right here in the search bar
in the search bar you will find a simple
way to find the data so for example if
i'm interested in cancer
you can see everything related to cancer
or if i want to
learn about dna
so here you will see dna highlighted
right so that's something that you can
do right here if you just want to get
started there's an excellent collection
of courses to get started and you will
find it right here getting started so if
you click on getting started if you're
new to bioinformatics or you're new to
omix and sequencing data you can go
right here
and you will see that there are several
courses to kind of get into it so
introduction to bioinformatics is a very
short course that you can complete for
free you don't need to pay to register
you just complete this course for free
there's also a course called bytes and
molecules and this course is a little
bit more comprehensive
and it has several different aspects
that you can learn about you know what
is dna what are what are these sequences
how is sequencing data generated what
are proteins and protein structures uh
introduction to genomics transcriptomics
and we'll have probably by tomorrow
introduction to metagenomics so you'll
learn about different types of omics if
you want to just get started with coding
you can use this introduction to
bioinformatics languages so this is a
course that's really designed to get you
started now after you've completed this
you will see that under your profile you
will start seeing points accumulating
and so when you see these accumulating
points essentially they are getting you
from a beginner who doesn't know a lot
to intermediate level to then an expert
that gives you some validation that you
know it and you can also validate it by
looking at the number of courses that
you've completed and the certificates
that you've gotten by completing those
courses
okay so i see that um somebody raised
their hand
um polo yet did you want to ask a
question
and
so go ahead you can unmute yourself and
ask your question or if you would like
to type it in you know okay yeah go
ahead
yes believe me yeah believe me yeah i
want to ask i am because i received the
email because i remember registering for
the
um i remember
registering for the
um for this
data science
omni and genetics so is it that the
clusters is going to be on zoom
or through
or on the portal we have to register on
the portal first
yes you have to register on the portal
uh so again you go to the programs and
did you already create a profile
i think i already did
okay yes i already
after you log in go to the programs tab
and right here these are three programs
offered by biomed so if you just type in
here biomed
okay you you uh okay biometals with two
m's biomed you can see the three
programs that we're discussing in these
orientation sessions are introduction to
bioinformatics
data science for biomedical data and
balkan single cell transphobic so today
we're talking about this program data
science for biomedical data
if you have not completed the
registration
take a look at this link it will look a
little bit different from what i'm
showing on the screen
okay thank you or jess we just posted
the link so take a look there and if you
have any questions then or just we would
be able to help you with that too
okay thank you
all right great uh and uh filani did you
have a question
yeah good evening everyone
yeah my question is
is there a means for internship like can
somebody get in training with you
each better have the basic of buying
information already
because i did the courses
of it so i want to probably practice
what i've learned or what i've known
because i i'm into data analysis and
i've done data science already
but just so far
it's a process so that i'm asking
okay well so yeah there are different
ways that you can use this these
different programs uh one of them is to
get training and so if you've completed
your training then you should focus on
your research project right so the goal
of this portal is to train you and then
give you the tools to work on an
independent project how do you do that
there are several ways that you can do
it if you already have a subscription on
the portal or you're part of a program
you simply go to your profile
and once you are in your profile you
will see that if you have 10 000 points
right here or more than 10 000 points
you can navigate to the projects tab
and start a new project okay so what
this new project will be is essentially
like a publication so you will see that
all the different steps here will
resemble a publication abstract methods
results discussion etc and this will be
useful for you to demonstrate that you
have really learned a lot of these
different types of data different types
of analysis and can do biological
interpretation
if you would like to have help for
someone to actually work with you as a
mentor the way that you can do that is
by joining the research fellowship a
research fellowship is a program that we
run
every
semester so right now we're in the fall
semester so we have the fall
research fellowship program it's going
to go from september until the end of
december and essentially the goal is to
prepare your project for the upcoming
conferences in bioinformatics so that
you can present so if you need more
details about that you can actually
reach out to our team you can reach out
to
support pine bio or marketing and find
bio and they can guide you on how to
register for the research fellowship
isa uh did you have a specific question
that i can answer
yes uh uh
good evening sir
uh i have a question on uh
machine learning
i did literally project on it uh
like uh
breast cancer
prediction
but still my question
is
on
uh already i give the question through
the chat that uh
dna
sequences i did a lot of things
but still i did not understand it so
please
can you help me
with a specific
website that i can go and register
i can follow so that
i can understand
okay well yeah that's a good point so
the data essentially um comes from the
process of sequencing and there are a
couple of courses that i could recommend
from here that you can actually get
started with
um for example this course on
transcriptomics will talk about how
uh the sequencing the process of next
generation sequencing works or you can
you know this is for rna you will find
the same for dna so you can look for
genomics for example and here you will
also have an explanation of sequencing
and what essentially you can do with
different sequences and how to analyze
sequencing or process sequencing data
depending on the level of complexity and
kind of technical uh questions that you
have
these are some of the courses that you
can use to kind of get started and
understand the process of sequencing the
different file formats how to process
them and one of the major benefits of
these courses is that they actually can
provide you with an overview of how to
build pipelines
and use some data sets from our
repository or from the public domain to
actually practice how to do that so here
for example we have the t by info
platform you will have access to this
platform as a part of these courses as
well and what you will see is different
ways to process rna-seq data so
transcriptomic data or genomic data so
here mutation variants you can see how
to use fastview files or sra files from
ncbi and turn them into genomic variant
calling files vcf files so these are
some of the tools that you will be able
to practice here
inside each one of these pipelines every
method has a link so you can actually
understand how the methods are connected
together and then if you wish to go into
more technical detail you can follow
those links
okay
kashaf is
willing to work in the company great
so please send your cv to ilia at pine
bio um
as a bioinformatician data science so
always looking for great talent so
please go ahead and send us your cv
and uh
all right thank you uh oh jesse okay are
there any other questions that i can
answer for now
email yes or just me right there shared
my email elia
fine dot file
okay so um i i think we are just
approaching
um how can you get the lecture material
so this lecture was reported
we're going to follow up by email and
share the recording with you you're
welcome to
watch that recording on youtube as well
we have a youtube channel where you will
find a lot of free resources that you
can go over you can learn about the
different programs like i said yesterday
we had the
overview orientation for
introduction to bioinformatics if you're
just getting started you can go for the
introduction to bioinformatics program
today we're talking about data science
and then tomorrow we're going to be
talking about transcriptomics with some
specific focus on transcriptomic data
analysis and interpretation
so
thank you everyone for joining today
again look out for those emails with the
recording for today with all the links
that we discussed with all the different
curricula
and thank you again for joining and for
being here today and we are looking
forward to seeing all of you in the
program itself
okay and uh
lane did you want to say anything else
i know just thanks everyone for coming
to the orientation
you